what are the job opportunities for
bachelor's master's and phd level
students in industry
what are the specific skill sets that is
required in such jobs what are the
technical and non-technical challenges
that they face
and does our education system equip our
students for such industrial jobs
these are the kinds of questions which
are at the top of every engineering
student's mind
not just injuring students but even
their professors and even the students
parents and who better to answer these
questions than someone who has had
extensive
technological experience through his
stint in an industry first and then as
an engineering professor
thankfully we have just such an
individual with us here today he is
professor ananduru bhattacharya so
professor bhattacharya
is a
faculty currently a faculty member in
the mechanical engineering department of
iit kharagpur and at the institute level
he has also been the associate dean of
international relations and ranking
formerly he was
a senior professional in intel general
motors and general electric
he is also an accomplished singer
and he has been instrumental in setting
up the academy of classical and folk
arts here at iit kharagpur
i am humbled to call him a friend and by
virtue of him being a senior here in the
department by almost a decade i have the
privilege of calling him not as
professor bhattacharya but very
affectionately as anuruddha
so ananda a very welcome to my small
youtube channel a big thanks
to you for sparing a large chunk of your
time here with us today
i'm sure all the people in our community
will be really really grateful to you
so before we can get into the hardcore
contentious questions let me first start
with a nice sweet question uh
by requesting you to please recount to
us
the very interesting carrier trajectory
that you have followed by first uh after
starting out uh from iit kharagpur as an
undergraduate student and then going to
your page in the us then your stint in
the industry and then coming back to
academia as a faculty member in the at
iit kharagpur
thank you thank you thank you jeevan
jyoti and thank you for that very kind
introduction i'm overwhelmed uh i
you have overstated quite a few things
so thank you anyway it's very kind of
you
just correct that i
i'm one of the co-pics of the academic
classical info cards it's probably i was
not instrumental in setting it up by any
stretch of imagination i have
contributed whatever i could
you said it's a very interesting career
trajectory
it's a very kind of you again so some
people may look at my career trajectory
and says oh what a confused person this
is
he doesn't know what he wants in life
anyway and uh so that has how
it's probably my nature to a certain
extent that i uh
i'm a little adventurous that way and
sometimes i also get bored
uh after a while so which
as a result of which i've tried both
academia and industry
etc now coming back to my uh what i did
in very short
as you know like just like you i did my
undergraduate over here uh i graduated
in 1997 with the b tech in mechanical
engineering so and
i'm quite old as you know yeah so what i
was saying is after my
btec in 1997 i moved to usa for my
what they call graduate studies over
there
uh i went to university of colorado at
boulder and there i did my master's in
1999 and then phd in 2001.
now what happened was during
the stint of my both masters and phd i
was fortunate to have a supervisor
who was a very well-known name in the
history in in the in the realm of heat
transfer his name is mahajan
but more interestingly
professor mahajan
after his phd from cornell university
spent close to 15 years in atnt bell
labs where he was an extremely
successful industrial r d researcher
and rising up to the rank of what is
called the bell labs fellow
fellow as many of you may know is the
highest rank that someone can achieve in
the technical ladder in in a technical
in a company
in a technology company
so that's the highest rank and many a
times equivalent to a vice president if
somebody follows the managerial track so
my supervisor my advisor was a bill labs
fellow and after that
he moved
to uh university of colorado as a
professor
and he set up the center what was called
the center for advanced manufacturing
and packaging of electronics
so i had the fortune to work with him
and by virtue of being in his research
group as well as being part of this
center
which was an industry academia
consortium
i had a direct exposure in a lot of
industry related problems
and probably that is where both my
advisors influence as well as exposure
in that industry
academia research center
that kind of
sparked that interest
spot my research interest or my interest
in applied research
okay
and
also what happened was during that time
i was the recipient of what is called
the ibm cooperative fellowship okay
i got it at the end of my first year
none of nothing to i don't deserve any
credit for that it was just i had to
submit the proposal it was my advisor's
proposal and it went in my name and
therefore i became what is called the
ibm co-op fellow
but the good thing was i had to do
something that was relevant to the
electronics industry
so my project was definitely in the
applied mode
and i had to justify why ibm should fund
me
okay
so as a result uh
when i
graduated i got a job in at intel
it was not as easy as i'm talking about
because i as i said i graduated in 2001
december 2001
and
when the whole world was going through a
deadly recession
and to top that just about a month
before my defense in october of 2001
9 11 happened
so there was no jobs anywhere
and then suddenly this i got an email
one day and i applied and anyway somehow
i got that job so therefore i joined
intel
uh
in chandler arizona which was which is
where you know the focus of their
packaging research was
in 2002 march 25 2002 so actually next
month i'm going to complete 20 years
off of my professional career
okay
so but anyway for certain reasons uh
which i'm not going to get into the
details into i
staying in the u.s and settling there
was not an option for me
uh so therefore i returned to india in
2003
and as you have said i i
worked in the industry
in india
in intel actually intel india in
bangalore
and then i had a short stint at general
motors uh actually
and after that i moved to general
electric
which is ge global research center in
bangalore as we know ge global research
for core mechanical engineering is one
of the most prestigious r d research
organizations across the world
especially their headquarters in upstate
new york where they have done some very
pioneering research
and so has intel labs so i was very
fortunate to be associated with
two of the world's most respected
companies
and working with some
extraordinarily smart people okay
so that i i do consider myself fortunate
to have to have them as my colleagues
and some of them as my very close
friends and their friendship continues
till today
uh
why the general motors i would like to
mention is
i joined gm and
from intel because at that time i
i mean i was told and i was somehow i
was convinced that i should move into
a company which does core mechanical
engineering because for a mechanical
engineer working in an electronics
company
and that too in india
there was a certain my career was
reaching some kind of a plateau
and what happened was 18 months into my
employment in gm
and let me tell you the gm was a very
high profile india science lab
had some extraordinary bright people
about hundreds of hundred of them
but then what happened was one fine day
about
18 months into my employment
there was a change in leadership over
there and the new leader the new cto of
gm general motors
decided to shut down india science lab
and therefore i i even went through the
experience of a layoff
okay nothing new and the reason i'm
trying to tell you is these are all part
and parcel of the of an industrial job
okay you get something but there are
certain risks involved and we have to be
we have to prepare for such
eventualities i'm sure some of your
junior colleague colleagues are facing
the same scenario right now as more
automotive companies are packing shop
that's true but
what i understand at least in india and
even in u.s also the job market is very
very bright very upbeat now so maybe
automotive sector
um
the traditional automotive sector may be
suffering something but again there is a
whole new thrust in electric mobility so
and probably i'll come to that people
it's very important to be nimble and to
be to pick up new skills right uh to be
to pick up new skills where where the
industry is heading yes
it's very important okay sure
you remember this is when we met first
you were a student over here yes i was a
psc student yes yeah and you had come
along with your senior devops in some
hotel in kolkata yes
workshop and
i was invited by your advisor
yes to come and be as an industry
participant over there so
yeah that time i was in gm
but
anyway so i went through a layoff
experience as well
thankfully
i got a job
pretty soon but um
yeah but let me tell you those few weeks
where
we're not yes
quite stressful i must say when you have
a family when you have dependents and
you suddenly lose your job
uh it's it's this is for no fault of
yours
it's part of industry okay
yeah if
if it's a performance issue and you lose
your job that's one thing you are
prepared yeah but on the other hand if
the cto says i'm going to address this
crowd and you go to the conference room
and then he says i have decided to close
down this group
it hits you yeah
for a few for a few minutes none of us
realize what has happened
you don't know how to process the news
we know how to react and suddenly okay
yeah and if this happens and let me tell
you this happens very suddenly it can
you you may not have a single inkling of
that
so i'm really excited that you brought
this up because
uh our future professionals people who
may be watching this they need to be
prepared for such an eventuality yes yes
yes these are they are see in every
every facet of life everywhere there is
a balancing factor okay
some good things some bad things some
rewards some risks higher the reward
higher the risk and so you started uh
you started at g in 2011 right
2012 2012 right okay
all right so genie experience was quite
varied you know what happened was
because g does
everything under the sun right there
your aviation your g oil and gas energy
power your industrial systems your ge
healthcare yeah
there used to be water also there used
to be even materials g plastics which
they sold off to another company so
so what happens general electric they
should probably be general so general
engineering is very very generous and
and when you are in that so these are
business units under the ge global
center it's a horizontal cuts across the
research organization cuts across all
these business units so depending on
where you are you get an opportunity to
you get a glimpse into all these
industries so that was an enriching
experience
so i work in the energy sector i work in
the healthcare sector a little bit in
transportation as well g locomotives you
may know um then appliances which they
sold out but g at some point uh even few
years back used to make you know
refrigerators and ovens
and washing machines
and induction cooktops etc so
i didn't know the induction cooktop has
so much of thermal engineering inside
you know i was
so that's a varied experience i got it
was very enriching
i didn't get a chance to work directly
on any project with aviation but my
teammates were working on that and
through their work
i could
i got an exposure to that that field as
well
so
yeah therefore that's kind and then i
joined here in 2015 and
thereafter you know so i've been
teaching i've been doing research
and the rest is history
and
i have some i have a now a reasonably
sized research group and good students
who are doing good work
and i'm also enjoying the teaching and
interactions with students of course
last two years have not been that great
because i miss the presence of the
students in class to be honest we all
have we all have we all we all do yes
i miss the touch of the chalkboard
and and especially so
the classes the way that our classes
used to be said your class almost always
preceded mine at least for the third
year yeah right so heat transfer
mechanics are solid so very good yeah
all right so thank you very much for
that brief recount i'm sure we are
missing out on many anecdotal stories
but in the interest of when we don't
know
so
uh okay so overall your basic training
has been in mechanical engineering
starting from your undergraduate days
through your phd
hardcore thermal science and engineering
uh so during your industrial stint uh
what kind of technical and non-technical
skills do you think you have to use the
most so
uh i know it's hard to differentiate
like you are applying yourself as a
human intelligence as opposed to
artificial intelligence to various
engineering problems and when you do so
you do not really differentiate between
what you learned as an undergraduate
what you learned as a phd student but
perhaps if you could give us some
glimpse of what kind of technical and
non-technical things you had to use
absolutely
so before that let me
tell you something about
what is what are the skills that any
industrial what are the broad skills
that that is expected out of an industry
professional okay whether it's r d or
whether it's uh
more of execution type or project man
whatever it is
there are three primary skills the first
one is your technical depth
technical knowledge
see you have to be
sound you you your fundamentals have to
be sound okay
and your understanding fundamental
understanding should be very good very
firm
and and that gives you the base that
gives you that gives you the foundation
based on which you can work you can you
can talk you can converse you can
communicate with confidence because if
that is weak then you know people are
not going to listen to you
right
so it's very important
now uh the second thing
is about
what i would say the strategic vision
okay now what do i mean by that
it's not about just the ceo cto cxos or
the vp engineering or the technical
fellows who should have this
at every stage however junior you are
you should know that what are the
strategic
objectives of your organization
and try to justify that how are you
contributing in your small way
in that direction
okay
and you have to ask yourself this
question right from day one why am i
doing this
okay or why am i learning this
is it important
is it going to contribute to the
company's strategic direction
okay
and this is very important you know g1
especially for technical people like us
we love technology there are certain
areas domains which are close to our
heart okay
but then
the industry direction is very dynamic
especially when you are talking about
high-tech industry semiconductor
industry you know here products
technologies become obsolete it's a very
fast moving industry and you have to
keep pace with that and that means that
sometimes you have to let go something
which is very close to your heart
okay
and this sometimes is very difficult for
researchers like us
okay so let me introduce you there for
just a moment
so
as i've already mentioned you uh i had
mentioned about this upcoming interview
to
the small group of people who
follow up in the community of her for
youtube channel and some of them had
posed some questions and one of the
important questions they had asked was
that what's the difference between
industrial research and development
versus academic research i think what
you just mentioned uh answers that
question that in academic research uh
you are kind of free to pursue as your
heart wants
which
may not always be possible in industry
yes
industry you have to you have to give
the business reason why you are doing
what you are doing okay
so
and then higher up you go the more
strong that is okay
so this is important but let me complete
what i was saying and then i will come
yes come to this come back to this in
more detail uh so i talked about
technical knowledge
and i talked about the strategy equation
that thinking okay
and the third one
is about your
mentorship
abilities
are you a good mentor
okay will you be able to work will you
be able to lead a project working with
other people
and finally working as a team motivate
them
and
and remember when you when you're
leading a project
it doesn't mean that you have to know
everything that's why you have experts
you form your team with experts right
how to get the best out of them how to
motivate them with words of appreciation
with rewards with proper direction
okay so this mentoring ability is very
important okay and sometimes it's not
just your team you have to be very
selfless over there
okay you should not be
and this is what sometimes many people
uh this is a quality you have to develop
you have to have a big heart
uh you have to be good here you have to
be good here okay
you have to you should not say that why
should i mentor him what's in it for me
it will come back later sometime not
immediate
but you should feel that satisfaction
by enabling somebody to realize his or
her dream
and trust me that if when he or she does
it
yeah you will be remembered
when when your mentee gets appreciated
he will say he or she will say that you
know this is because
professor jeevan jyoti chakravarthy was
the person who motivated me i'm indebted
to him right so this is something we are
quite accustomed to seeing within our
academic field so as teachers as
supervisors advisors we always have this
feeling naturally that we want our
students to perform better than we ever
did to go beyond what we are
what we ever could do
so it's quite natural so but but it is
very heartening for me to listen to
these words that such such kind of
feeling
also exists in industry
absolutely now because i have to ask you
this so because your experiences have
been obvious at the elite industries the
intel gngs which are like the dream jobs
of any of any engineer or respective of
the department so does does this culture
uh exist in maybe smaller companies also
or is it is it only limited to the elite
industries no no i think it should
it should and because uh
you know otherwise you cannot grow
exactly when you grow
uh and you you become a leader like that
because you show the direction to people
and you groom tomorrow's leaders they
will grow and then you will grow even
higher that's how things are probably
one of the reasons why these companies
became elite in the first place was that
they had this work culture to begin with
yes no i think i i don't take it i think
i'm sure the smaller companies also have
that okay so these these are core values
that one must have
and
and people who are successful whoever i
have seen and as i said and i was
fortunate enough to work with extremely
smart people
technically smart who have
made i mean i'm you know i i worked with
somebody who was a co-inventor of
bluetooth radio
you think about that impact yeah
then dr ajay bhatt intel fellow
he was a co-inventor of usb
usb technology
so these are the people i was fortunate
to interact with and if you think about
it this is the level at which they they
have impacted
the industry
and even the even people like us i mean
think about without bluetooth and
and without uh without usb where would
we be today we would not be having this
we would not be having this conversation
exactly
so
now how did they reach and why would
such people talk to me
when i was probably just five years into
the industry
but i i cannot tell you given the way
the way they spoke to me and it was
almost like we are equals
okay what do you think i am you know
what is asking me
okay this is this i i have a problem and
this is what we are thinking to it what
do you think about this and can you
imagine that's the level of humility
which has led them to go
that and the kind of respect they have
for such a junior colleague like me so
that is important so three things
again to summarize what i was saying
technical knowledge
strategic vision
and mentoring ability right i will also
just say this is something that
we patrol to us in ge
if you look at your career progression
is very important for the students who
are listening to
if you look at the different phases of
your professional career
four
there are four stages learn
do
guide shape
okay learn do guide shape
so when you first enter the industry
if you're going to a big industry et
cetera
majority of your part is going to be
learning
okay
it's a learning phase and you must use
it go and talk to as many people as
possible go attend lectures even if it
directly is not related to what you are
doing
but at the same time the two aspect you
must do it very well whatever
task you have been given
do it
and exceed expectations there
because remember in the first few years
one year or two years
it is the stage where you're
establishing your credibility
you may have done very well as an as a
student but i don't know you
so i don't know how how good you are
going to be in an industry setting so i
will give you something
which i know you can based on my
understanding okay where you will not
fail
so definitely it's not and so your
objective as the employee should be to
do it well and to do it exceedingly well
so that now your boss has more
confidence on you and gives you a higher
responsibility
okay so learn and do typically goes and
as you progress
your learning learning now is less and
doing is more
and then
as you do things better and learning
never stops please keep that in mind
okay learning never stops
then as you do things better and better
then you go
then you rise up and then you go to the
guide mode okay then they said okay you
know this guy is doing well he does his
job well he also contributes to others
so maybe it's time to
give him a project to lead
let him work with four people
he he's going to be the leader and he
was having you will as a leader you will
have your own
part to execute
and then you will also be guiding the
rest of your team members okay
and then this guidance this guidance
part keep on increasing so you become a
team leader then you become an
organization leader and so on and so
forth
and finally when you reach a certain
level of seniority
that is where the word shape comes so
what you do is not just of course you
are contributing to your own
organization your own company
but you are also
shaping the direction of the entire
industry whether it's automotive whether
it's aviation whether it's power whether
it's semiconductors okay
so
of course usb
is not intel's
discovery alone was
involved but so were other people from
other industries
you also start influencing the road map
okay for example in electronics there
used to be what is called ksi a
semiconductor industries association
roadmap that is getting now replaced by
what is called the ieee
hir heterogeneous integration roadway so
these are the road maps of different
industry sectors which has inputs from
academics from industry this is where
you are shaping the future right so
learn do guide and shape
these are the four progress four stages
and they will progress
i have seen many people you know i i can
do this so i am there for three years i
am still being given something i think i
can do better yes of course you can do
better but you have to be patient
it's not important definitely you
probably have the capability but the
time will come so be patient and keep
working and as i said keep working
keep exceeding expectations
okay so that's my based on my uh reading
of few years in the industry that's the
advice i can give so more than a few
years i would say
i can almost feel certain parallels with
the at least the initial stages of it
with the kind of experiences of
beginning phd student experiences so
first he has to learn and then he has to
do and then prove himself to his
supervisor and then maybe he will be
given more independence
a greater responsibility perhaps to even
mended undergraduates master students
and that's how he gets shaped as a
possible future faculty candidate
himself
researcher and also was the former dean
r d of iit kharagpur yes so he was
telling somewhere and i was listening
and he said that
when the first phd student comes and say
okay respect itself what should i be
working on
i will tell you that okay this is what
you are going to work on
and maybe this is how you should work
one
so he goes
does that job comes back said okay
respected said i have done whatever i
had to
what next
then i will tell him
what he should be working on but i won't
tell him how
yeah
that's for him to figure out
then he goes around ask goes to the
library figures out how people have done
before etc etc and then he
maybe comes back after one year and says
and comes back doesn't mean that in one
year they didn't talk but
after one year that job is done and they
said okay sir i have completed this
problem what next
i said when he says what next i want you
to look at him
because now you have matured enough to
define the next problem yourself exactly
okay and this is what my phd advisor you
since you brought up the phd student
things now
he used to say that your phd is
successful when not only have you
successfully done what you had to do to
get your thesis
but you have defined problems
which is good enough for somebody else
to work on and get his page differences
so
this is uh so these are probably
where we can draw the parallel with what
we are saying with shaping yes keeping
the lord guide you know learn to lie
okay yep absolutely
and so coming back to your things that
what what were my uh
what did i or what skills did i pick up
during my student days
um of course i will go backwards phd
definitely enabled me
to work on unknown problems that's the
skill
that's that's a different skill you need
right
i don't know there's a problem i don't
know what the solution is
when you say
unknown problems it doesn't necessarily
mean that
uh the specific kind of problems that
you did during your phd rather this
innate ability or developing this
aptitude to tackle no matter what the
unknown problem is that innate
absolutely that absolutely and it is
yeah it is very important because phd is
not just about you know writing a thesis
and a few papers and working on a
particular domain
it's an education
okay it's an education it's a skill that
you pick up during those whatever three
four five years
of your doctoral studies
when you gain the confidence that okay
if i am given a problem for which the
solution is unknown
i know how to attack it systematically
how to think through the problem and
come to a meaningful solution
right okay so that is what a phd
or even to a certain extent the masters
also teaches you a research teaches you
right okay so that's the skills you pick
up you can pick it up other um you don't
necessarily have to have a phd you can
pick it up even through your job as well
but this is what it gives you a proven
so this is something the other thing
that i learned from my phd which has
definitely helped me
is about how to communicate your ideas
and this is a very important skill you
know because
which has helped me later
if somebody asked me that how what are
you working on i should have a 30 second
answer i should have a 3 minute answer i
should have a 30 minute answer okay and
depending on who i am talking to and how
much time i have i should be able to
drive home the point
okay
so it's very important that came out to
be very important in
industry because let's say i met one of
the very senior managers or one of the
very senior technical persons let's
start there but
and i meet him in the corridor we are
walking towards the cafeteria or maybe
we it's called the elevator pitch right
you know because we meet at the elevator
and come to us
and if i now start telling him that what
are the equations i solved and what are
the what are the algorithms
yeah you don't do that right yeah what
is the key message yeah okay
and and this is important to pick up
this this i learned
during my stint at phd because as i said
i was part of this
research center and they used to have
this industrial advisory board meetings
twice a year
and where i would go and i will probably
get two to three minutes to talk about
my phd research it was very important to
organize your thoughts and communicate
what what would be the key takeaways
so you have to think that what is that i
am going to present
which these people are going to remember
what are the three what are the two or
three key points i'm going to drive home
impactful points okay right
so this i picked up here and
during a phd and
technical knowledge definitely you know
from your eug to phd we all pick it up
and
it is very very important let me tell
you at every stage of life
and finally i would say the
as you probably know g1 informally
during my
undergraduate days
yeah i used to i used to attend classes
regularly but i also spent a lot of time
on extra academic activities yes um
i probably a lot of time in the music
room a lot of time in the in dramatics
where yourselves
on the sports field not necessarily uh
uh playing but cheering for my hall or
for for my team for those of you who
don't know here at iit kharagpur we call
our hostels as halls so our
[Music]
yeah a lot of practice
let's just not get into that let's not
get into that i am not from ra i will
not allow you to
do an archicad tempo here
no so what happened was these exposures
and these activities uh
you know taught me about team work
about how to
how to be happy at your friend's success
exactly okay how to celebrate your peers
success again very important you know to
be selfless because if you can if you
celebrate somebody else's success they
will also celebrate your success let me
tell you okay
so it's very very important and i think
to a certain extent we do have this
culture of celebrating our friends
success
compared to what we the kind of culture
that we usually have in our schools
where it's a very individualistic
pursuit of one's own excellence compared
to that
it's not just limited to the iits or
nits i believe
across all uh engineering issues i think
there is this uh culture of camaraderie
uh a feeling of very very convenient
atmosphere of of excelling together uh
this celebration cheerful celebration uh
i think this and and
probably the the small minority of
students who do not really appreciate
this this might be a good message to
them that uh
even if you are thinking in a very
individualistic excellence manner also
uh
the the even if you try to probably
pretend that you are
you are you are cheering for your
friends
that that pretence can actually turn you
into something better than what you wear
yeah and let me tell you will uh
it gives you a lot of happiness and
satisfaction yes ultimately ultimately
life is about being happy okay
other things are all secondary and so
try to derive happiness in what you do